el turístico estado de Río de Janeiro
popular por sus paradisíacas playas
sufre las consecuencias de la emergencia
climática imágenes de un sepelio en
petrópolis en febrero solo en ese mes y
en dicha localidad murieron más de 100
personas por un desastre que según
expertos podría haberse evitado en
yacareciño una Favela solo 10 minutos
del turístico estadio maracaná los
ciudadanos exigen acción inmediata del
gobierno local pero no obtienen
respuesta
ya hemos informado lo que sucede todos
los años ya lo reportamos lo filmamos
ahora con la tecnología lo subimos a
redes sociales pero parece que nadie
escucha que nadie lo ve no les importa
en esta Favela la mayoría de la
población vive bajo condiciones de
pobreza y sus casas ubicadas en los
cerros no resisten las fuertes
precipitaciones y están expuestas a
deslizamientos
la alcaldía de molerá esta casa porque
una parte ya se cayó los vecinos no
saben lo que deben hacer en este tipo de
casos
la ong greenpeace Brasil denuncia la
responsabilidad de las autoridades en la
emergencia por el clima al no diseñar un
plan de adaptación climática algunos
activistas y políticos locales
consideran que la inacción del gobierno
se debe al racismo
los habitantes de yacareciño viven
racismo ambiental en esta época del año
la gente pobre de nuestro estado se
despierta y se acuesta con miedo a la
lluvia
el presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva asegura que los efectos de
la emergencia climática agravan aún más
la pobreza pero su gobierno mantiene
políticas basadas en energías fósiles
una de las Industrias más contaminantes
para el medio ambiente